[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: All right,
welcome everyone.
Thanks so much for joining.
Today, Google Chicago
is excited to welcome
to cast of "Superior
Donuts," which
is a comedy on CBS about
the owner of a small donut
shop in a quickly gentrifying
neighborhood, that takes place
right here in Chicago.
You'll recognize the
cast and crew here today
from many TV shows and movies.
They're also a very talented
group of stand-up comedians,
and are in the middle of a
coast-to-coast stand-up comedy
tour.
They're going to be
performing at Zanies tonight.
And tonight also marks
the season two premiere
of their show, "Superior
Donuts," which you can
check out at 8 o'clock on CBS.
So, please join me in welcoming,
Maz Jobrani, Jermaine Fowler,
David Koechner, and Rell Battle.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
JERMAINE FOWLER: That's
right, mother fuckers.
MAZ JOBRANI: Hello.
DAVID KOECHNER: Good afternoon.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Great
crowd, thanks for coming out.
RELL BATTLE: Really
packed it out.
Thank y'all so much.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Really packed
it out, too many people.
I'm a little nervous now.
Welcome to all you guys for
coming out this evening,
appreciate you for being here.
MAZ JOBRANI: Skipping work.
SPEAKER 2: This is awesome.
DAVID KOECHNER: They need
a reason to skip work.
RELL BATTLE: The drugs
are kicking in, excuse us.
SPEAKER 2: So, I think we should
start every Google meeting just
like that.
That would be freaking awesome.
So thank you guys
for being here.
We are excited to
be able to have
the cast of a show
that's being shot--
that's based on uptown Chicago.
And having you guys here,
a handful of questions
that any of you can answer.
I am excited because
I actually used
to live in uptown,
which if any of you guys
have lived in uptown, you know
how challenging that can be,
still to this day.
And uptown has-- you've got
your somewhat disenfranchised.
You've got lots of different
kinds of people living there.
opportunities for improvement.
RELL BATTLE: Just
say minorities.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm playing.
SPEAKER 2: You've
got minorities,
you've got everything.
So, what do you want
the folks in uptown--
like, how are they
served by your show?
And what things would you say
to them if they were here?
Just curious.
RELL BATTLE: I think
our cast is very mixed.
So we're pretty much-- that's
what uptown looks like.
Every type of
person represented.
African-Americans, white.
He's Middle Eastern.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I am, yeah.
RELL BATTLE: The other guy.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Oh, Maz, yeah.
RELL BATTLE: Diane
Guerrero, she's Colombian.
Judd's character is Jewish.
We cover every
base, pretty much.
We're a diverse show.
So it represents the
real uptown of Chicago.
SPEAKER 2: Very nice.
So we always talk about, here
at Google, unconscious bias,
right?
And it's something that
we all obviously have,
whether we're aware of
it or not, funny enough.
So can you kind
of share with us--
as you guys approach some of the
shows, how they're structured,
how they're written--
how you're kind
of tackling that?
DAVID KOECHNER: We did a
whole show on that, didn't we?
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Yeah, we actually did.
Unconscious bias.
DAVID KOECHNER: Was that last
year or was that this year?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Last season.
DAVID KOECHNER: Right.
JERMAINE FOWLER: This
season was micro-aggression.
DAVID KOECHNER: Right.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Sort of.
MAZ JOBRANI: Wait, which one
was the unconscious bias one?
RELL BATTLE: We don't
watch our show often.
SPEAKER 2: Was it the one
where you had the hoodie on
and you said, I am just a
black man with a hoodie.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Baseball episode.
RELL BATTLE: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
JERMAINE FOWLER: We did that
last episode where people don't
really know they might be doing
something racist or prejudice,
but it's just instilled in them
that they've been conditioned
to think that way.
And that was the episode
we did last year.
This season, we touched
on micro-aggression.
And I'm pretty sure some people
might have experienced that,
whether that be--
I don't know if
Google does that.
It makes me laugh.
It just makes me laugh,
Google might do that.
But I worked at certain jobs and
I've been asked certain things.
Like, in this
particular episode,
Franco gets asked, hey, man,
you watch the basketball game
last night?
Jimmy Butler had
a terrible game.
Might need you to suit up.
You know, that was one
line the guy said to me.
I'm like, hey, look, I don't
really watch basketball.
And the guy's like, really?
And I'm like, man,
fuck you, man.
I used to get that a lot.
I kind of still
get that shit, man.
It annoys me the most.
DAVID KOECHNER: Basketball
or boxing, I'm assuming.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I like boxing.
DAVID KOECHNER: You
follow boxing, yeah?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Boxing's cool.
MAZ JOBRANI: Do you
watch basketball?
RELL BATTLE: I
actually follow both.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
No, I like skate--
I actually like X Games, man.
MAZ JOBRANI: You
watch the X Games?
JERMAINE FOWLER: I
like the X Games a lot.
RELL BATTLE: Really?
MAZ JOBRANI: How
often do they do that?
JERMAINE FOWLER: He's doing it.
You all see what--
MAZ JOBRANI: How often--
is that a four year thing,
or is that every year?
JERMAINE FOWLER: X
Games are every year.
MAZ JOBRANI: OK.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Not like
the Olympics or anything.
MAZ JOBRANI: Well, they call
it the games, I thought maybe--
JERMAINE FOWLER: Nah.
It's just, you know--
RELL BATTLE: What
was the question?
MAZ JOBRANI: I'm Middle
Eastern and I watch soccer.
SPEAKER 2: It was
about unconscious bias.
MAZ JOBRANI: So I fit the--
Middle Eastern
people like soccer.
DAVID KOECHNER: I'm
white and I love guns.
MAZ JOBRANI: There you go.
DAVID KOECHNER:
Guns and limiting
other people's liberty.
[LAUGHTER]
JERMAINE FOWLER: He couldn't
even pronounce liberty.
That's how white he is.
DAVID KOECHNER:
Limiting liberty.
[LAUGHTER]
MAZ JOBRANI: And he's being
served by Mueller today,
later, yeah?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yeah, they
have an indictment on him.
SPEAKER 2: That's awesome.
So, it's interesting that
you talk about stereotypes
because oftentimes,
African-Americans are always
seen as, back in the
day, you used to say,
well, you can tap dance, right?
You can dance.
You can play ball.
You can do this.
And you guys are
comedians, which
is also an area where there's
lots of African-Americans.
So, how do you toe
the line between being
able to share your
message and not
being stereotyped yourselves?
JERMAINE FOWLER: You got to
be honest with yourself, man.
If you like things, you
like certain things,
like the things you like.
It's funny, I grew up in
DC, all black neighborhood,
some Hispanic.
And I remember--
I guess I was
skateboarding around town
and I was really
into like filmmaking,
and shit that wasn't relative
to my family growing up.
My family loved boxing and
basketball and all that stuff.
So I got called a
white boy a lot.
DAVID KOECHNER: Did you really?
JERMAINE FOWLER: I did.
SPEAKER 2: So
would you say Oreo?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Oreo.
I got Oreo sometimes.
And I hated that
because you can--
it's so weird because
I feel like the more
you're trying to be--
the more you try to
cater to other people,
the more you lose less of who
you want to be and who you are.
So I never really cared about
what people thought about me.
Because the more you think
about you becoming a stereotype
or are you not
being a stereotype,
it's just going to eat you
up and really make you--
it'll just ruin your day.
It's just exhausting.
MAZ JOBRANI: I
think the show also
has a good representation
from liberal to conservative
and different colors
in the show actually.
So I play an
Arab-American in there.
I play an Iraqi-American
who is conservative
and a Trump supporter.
So you have that,
and then you've
got the young African-American
guy who's very liberal.
And then you got--
DAVID KOECHNER: Disenfranchised,
blue collar, white guy.
MAZ JOBRANI: Yeah.
And then you got the
older Jewish guy.
So you got every person.
And then you got the female.
You got, now, the
young Latina female.
And then you've got
the older female who's
been in the neighborhood
and she's tough,
and she comes from
an Italian family.
So everybody's covered.
So we get to bring out
a subject, any subject,
and give all these different
points of view on it.
SPEAKER 2: Which is awesome,
because you're not even Iraqi,
are you?
MAZ JOBRANI: I'm Iranian.
SPEAKER 2: Iranian, right?
MAZ JOBRANI: Yeah.
I wanted them to do
an Iranian character,
but they wanted someone
from a war-torn country.
And I said, well, Iran
was in a war with Iraq.
But then they said, we think
that the general public
might not remember that war.
[LAUGHTER]
At least in America.
And I said, all right.
I said, OK, touche.
DAVID KOECHNER: It wasn't
covered intensively.
MAZ JOBRANI: It's a shame.
It's a shame, but you know
how they say Americans,
we don't really pay attention to
the rest of the world, really.
DAVID KOECHNER: We didn't
cover the 1953 CIA coup.
MAZ JOBRANI: We did
not cover that coup.
And also, by the way, we
weren't at war with Iran.
If we'd been in war with Iran,
maybe the Iranian character
would have worked out.
But then again, we may be
going to war with Iran.
So, maybe the guy
will become Iranian
in the next couple
of seasons if Trump
keeps going the way he's going.
DAVID KOECHNER: We'll
find an Iraqi to play him.
MAZ JOBRANI: We'll get
an Iraqi to play him.
That's how it goes.
JERMAINE FOWLER: That's
the balance right there.
SPEAKER 2: So how
would you respond
to some of the pushback
on how realistic
you think the show is?
DAVID KOECHNER: Wait,
first, is there pushback?
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Is there pushback?
MAZ JOBRANI: And is it
supposed to be realistic?
I mean it's not a documentary.
It's a sitcom.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yeah,
we're having fun.
SPEAKER 2: True enough.
MAZ JOBRANI: I mean,
was Cheers really a bar
owned by a baseball
player that--
RELL BATTLE: They shot
"Cheers" on a lot in LA.
That's as real as it can get.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
It wasn't Boston?
SPEAKER 2: All right,
well that's perfect.
Because a lot of times people
say that, in Chicago, it's
very, very segregated.
So the chances of
actually having
all of those different groups
represented, consistently
anywhere is very, very slim.
So, it's interesting that you
have a platform for showing
how that could come together.
But I just wonder
what commentary--
MAZ JOBRANI: That's like the
reverse criticism of "Friends,"
which was in New York.
And everyone was like,
they're all white.
And now we got a mixed
group, and they're like,
they're too mixed.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's too mixed.
Hey, tone that shit down, man.
RELL BATTLE: Mexicans
don't eat donuts.
Get out of here.
[LAUGHTER]
What?
MAZ JOBRANI: This is
a shop in an area that
is being gentrified
that still has people
from the old
neighborhood still there.
So it's kind of a crossroads.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Yeah, gentrification
plays a huge part in the show.
We always talk about it.
That's one thing we
can all agree on,
this neighborhood is changing.
And it's funny, because I've
done Zanies Comedy Club down
at old town a bunch of times.
And I just realized
driving down here,
Dave told us that
Caprini-Green--
SPEAKER 2: Cabrini-Green?
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Cabrini-Green was a project--
DAVID KOECHNER: It's
a mile from there.
SPEAKER 2: It was
It's now a Target.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It used
to be this building, right?
I'm just playing.
It wasn't Google, was it?
SPEAKER 2: No.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
But it was funny--
SPEAKER 2: It's a Target now.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
It's a Target now?
SPEAKER 2: Yep,
Target's everywhere.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
That's hilarious.
MAZ JOBRANI: And Google isn't?
You talked about
Target like, Target's
taking over everything.
Oh, wait a minute.
To find a Target,
you've got to use
Google to find where they are.
They're all offended.
[LAUGHTER]
JERMAINE FOWLER: We're
just playing, man.
MAZ JOBRANI: That's not funny.
Target's the enemy, not Google.
We love you guys, give
us thought, please.
JERMAINE FOWLER: We
were just playing.
These guys are great.
[LAUGHTER]
They're going to change the
algorithm of our names now.
Be all negative.
SPEAKER 2: So David, you spent a
lot of time on the comedy scene
here in Chicago.
Did that have anything to
do with you taking the role
or not taking the role, or
being more excited about it
because you could
identify with it?
DAVID KOECHNER:
Probably a little bit
more excited about it.
In fact, I told
this story before.
When I saw it was
announced-- because I
don't know if you guys know
this, but it's based on a play.
"Superior Donuts" was a
play set here in Chicago,
and workshopped at the
Mary-Arrchie Theatre
Company, and then
Steppenwolf Theater,
and then went to Broadway.
And I saw it announced in the
trades and for some reason,
I said to myself, I'm
going to be in that.
Just because I figured, I
don't know, it's my turn.
But I just had a feeling,
and sometimes you do.
And then lo and
behold, there it was.
But yeah, I'm very happy.
Now, a lot of my friends
auditioned for the part
and didn't get it, so
they're not very happy.
The real authentic Chicagoans
didn't actually get it.
So yeah, that's a lot of fun.
SPEAKER 2: That's cool.
So you've got family,
you're out in California,
and I heard you guys
have a grueling schedule.
How do you balance all of that?
That's a lot.
DAVID KOECHNER: With intention.
JERMAINE FOWLER: With Shauna.
Shauna's our publicist,
she's right there.
DAVID KOECHNER: But you're
talking about work--
SPEAKER 2: In general, right?
That's something
that a lot of times--
I'm asking it very deliberately.
A lot of times--
this is unplugged a little bit--
women always get
asked that, right?
We always say, oh, you
got kids, you got this,
how are you balancing it all?
But I think that, a
lot of times, people
don't realize that men
have to balance that, too.
So I just wanted to know
how you do all of that.
DAVID KOECHNER: The good news is
that our schedule is actually--
to work in a multi-cam,
you're actually
working less than
30 hours a week.
MAZ JOBRANI: Oh, no,
it's close to 40.
It is, I did the math.
DAVID KOECHNER: OK.
MAZ JOBRANI: I thought
it was less than 30
until I stopped seeing my
kids on Monday and Tuesday.
And I was like, oh that's
because we're shooting all day.
DAVID KOECHNER: But
for instance, Wednesday
is when our work week
starts with our table read.
We get there at 10:00
and we're out at 2:00.
That's a pretty good day.
And that goes on for
three days in a row.
MAZ JOBRANI: You're
absolutely right.
DAVID KOECHNER: And then,
sometimes Mondays are 10 hours.
And sometimes,
Tuesdays are 10 hours.
MAZ JOBRANI: 10 to 12,
both of those, yeah.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Multi-cam
hours are a little easier.
MAZ JOBRANI: I'm
not complaining.
I'm just saying, yeah,
I agree with you.
DAVID KOECHNER: Every day, I
can take my kids to school.
That's huge.
And the show happens to shoot
10 minutes from my house,
so it's perfect for me.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
So it's easy to put
all that together.
DAVID KOECHNER:
Yeah, but in general,
I think you have to have
the intention that I'm
going to be there for my
kids as much as I can be.
Or be available.
SPEAKER 2: Very nice.
I can appreciate that.
So you guys have a show
premiering tonight.
It's coming out.
It's going to be on tonight
at 8 o'clock Central
Standard time, 9
o'clock Eastern time.
What do you want us
to know about that?
What do you want us to
know about this season?
How is it different?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Well,
the first season is always
just an introductory season.
You're just trying to relay
information for the new viewers
and the viewers in
the first season.
It's a lot of regurgitation.
It just kind of gets
a little repetitious.
DAVID KOECHNER: You're really
establishing, for the audience,
the primary relationship of
the show that people buy into.
And the peripheral characters,
you're exploring less so.
Because week to
week, like, no, no,
this is the primary
relationship, focus on this.
And I know you guys did have
a lot of that same like, hey,
wait a minute,
hey wait a minute.
JERMAINE FOWLER: In
the second season,
we're really just kind of
letting everything breathe.
And we get to open all the
characters up a little more.
We get to explain why Maz
thinks the way he does
or where Dave is coming from.
DAVID KOECHNER: Introducing
a new character.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Yeah, Diane Guerrero.
SPEAKER 2: Tell us about
that, and her organic truck.
DAVID KOECHNER: Food truck.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Oh, yeah.
So Diane Guerrero, she was
in "Orange is the New Black."
She plays Sophia and she
owns this organic food truck.
And it's sort of a threat
to Arthur's business.
And so they get into it.
But deep down, Arthur
sort of respects her
because she has this work
ethic that he can get behind.
SPEAKER 2: That's awesome.
Can't wait to see that.
We're all huge fans of donuts
and of all things organic.
So, I think it hits two
really great areas for us.
JERMAINE FOWLER: What's
your favorite donut though?
SPEAKER 2: My favorite donut?
Hey, didn't everybody
ask you guys that?
So, I like glazed.
I'm old fashioned.
I like the old fashioned glazed.
Just give it to me
straight and easy.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
I'm the same way.
SPEAKER 2: Real simple stuff.
"Superior Donuts"-- and I know,
as the executive producer,
you're the actor, and
so you also have some
say in what happens,
or I assume so.
So clearly, it's a
platform for dealing
with lots of social issues.
I know that you
mentioned the one where
you were talking
about the hoodie,
and you're with all cops,
and you weren't sure
if that was the right time
to be talking about that.
In a couple of
different episodes,
there was one where they
thought that perhaps you
took one of the pieces of art or
something that was on the wall,
or some kind of
sports memorabilia
that was on the wall.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Same episode, right.
DAVID KOECHNER:
The baseball, yeah.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yeah, Arthur's
home run baseball that he got.
SPEAKER 2: So comedy
and sitcoms have often
been used as a platform for
addressing social issues.
How is "Superior
Donuts" any different?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Well,
I'll tell you this.
I've done stand-up
about 10 years.
And you know, I'm used to taking
things from news headlines,
and going on stage
and yapping about it.
So it was pretty
easy to go from that
to doing "Superior Donuts"
because that's exactly
what we're basically doing.
In the writers room, we
bring up these issues
as potential topics to
talk about in episodes.
And all I have to do
in there is give them
my experiences dealing with
these particular issues.
Say we're talking about
the unconscious bias
episode, where the cop
was following me around.
And I'm like, hey, you know,
one time that happened to me.
A friend of mine--
I watched a friend of mine
get his ass beat by a cop
back in Maryland and it was the
first time I ever seen that.
It really changed the way I
looked at police officers.
So I tell them these stories.
And what happens is they
sort of include them
in certain parts and scenes.
And as an actor, it motivates
me to get certain areas
to get emotional.
Because I really
do get emotional
when I do these scenes,
especially when I'm
doing it with Judd, because
Judd is masterful, you know?
But those topics
are just something
you're supposed to talk about.
Especially in a show
like this, where
it takes place in a
gentrifying area, where
everyone is clashing.
You know what I mean?
And you've got to talk about it.
DAVID KOECHNER: I think we
do a pretty good job of not
making the decision for
the audience either.
We bring up other
sides of an argument,
or an idea, or a
cultural difference.
But we don't make a
resolution for everybody,
which I think is probably more
satisfying for an audience
that we're not
preaching to them.
So we're all like, most
Americans, there are two sides
to look at.
And so, I think we do a
pretty good job of bringing up
both sides.
MAZ JOBRANI: And the
writers, you know?
Early on last season, there was
an article written in the "New
York Times," and there's
been several articles
like this throughout, for the
depiction of Arab-Americans,
Iranian-Americans,
Middle-Eastern
Americans, Muslim Americans,
in film and television,
and how negative
those depictions are.
I remember I got that article
and I took it to the writers.
And Bob Daily, who's
the showrunner,
said, oh, I already saw this
and I've already spread it out
amongst all the writers.
So that was good for me to hear.
And so one of the
things they try to do--
and I've encouraged
them to when they write,
and I get happy
when they do-- is
they don't necessarily just base
the jokes on your background
or your ethnicity.
And just because you're
of a certain ethnicity
doesn't mean that you're
going to think a certain way.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Not
going to be a stereotype.
MAZ JOBRANI: So
that's kind of cool
when they have
something like, again,
if the guy's a jerk, he's
just a jerk, whether he's Arab
or not, or white or
black or whatever.
And if he's cool,
he's just cool.
And in the end--
because I play the nemesis.
You know, the guy
who kind of wants
to buy the donut shop from
Judd Hirsch's character.
In the end, there are
episodes where we all
have each other's back.
So, it is a community,
even if there's
some of that stuff happening.
SPEAKER 2: That's cool.
DAVID KOECHNER: Really,
I guess, so you're
asking the difference.
Our show, Lilly, is a cultural--
SPEAKER 2: [? Lilly. ?]
Cultural barometer for America.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Listen, every
press stop we go to, Dave--
boom-- it's the
culture barometer.
DAVID KOECHNER: Because
it's true, folks.
MAZ JOBRANI: He's made T-shirts.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's the truth.
MAZ JOBRANI: He's got cultural
barometer t-shirts and hats.
JERMAINE FOWLER: We
are the new news.
We are the new news.
DAVID KOECHNER: Watch
you guys all go, eww.
We're self-important.
JERMAINE FOWLER: We like to pat
ourselves on the back a lot.
SPEAKER 2: Speaking
of self, Maz,
I know that you spent
some time on the NPR show,
you've done a couple of Ted
talks, now you're doing this.
Tell us more about--
which, love Ted talks.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I didn't know
you did a fucking Ted Talk.
MAZ JOBRANI: I did
two of them, man.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Send
me the link, man.
MAZ JOBRANI: You
got to look me up.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I will, man.
MAZ JOBRANI: Have you IMDB'd me?
I am the cultural
barometer of this show.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I
did not know that.
That's awesome.
MAZ JOBRANI: What
was the question?
SPEAKER 2: The
question was just,
how does this show, this role--
how are you using it as a
part of your overall career
or another sounding board?
Or just, in relation
to most other things
you do, how does this relate?
MAZ JOBRANI: The
beauty of it is,
we are doing what we love doing,
as I'm sure a lot of you guys
are.
My parents, being
immigrant parents,
wanted me to be a
lawyer or a doctor.
And I did not go that path.
I became an actor.
And in that, I've been able to
do acting and stand-up comedy
in "Wait Wait...
Don't Tell Me!", which is a
radio show, and the Ted talks,
which is me presenting things.
So, it's all part
of the same thing.
And the underlying theme
of a lot of stuff that I do
is, I try to represent myself in
a good way, in a positive way,
in a different way.
As we know, there's a lot
of negative stereotypes
of people from Middle
Eastern backgrounds.
And there's a big push,
an anti-immigrant push,
in this country currently.
I mean, some guy in Kansas
shot two Indian dudes.
Killed one, and
then told somebody
that he had shot two Iranians.
He got the wrong
people first of all.
They hadn't done anything,
they were just at a bar.
And this guy was
just some crazy dude.
And this kind of
stuff is happening.
So, my hope, in the long
run, is that the more
we get people of different
backgrounds in the media,
the more people can
judge for themselves.
And see, and go, oh,
wow, these people
are just ordinary people.
When I did my first
stand-up special,
which was "The Axis of
Evil Comedy Special,"
one of the comments we got was--
because it wasn't
just for comedians
of Middle Eastern-American
backgrounds performing.
There was Middle
Easterners in the audience.
And we got some
emails saying, wow,
I didn't know you
people laughed.
And it was true.
You don't see our people
laughing anywhere.
Except an evil
like, [EVIL LAUGH],,
you know? (IRANIAN
ACCENT) I will kill you
in the name of Allah!
JERMAINE FOWLER: There it is.
MAZ JOBRANI: That, they've seen.
But they've never seen a guy
just be like, [LAUGHING]..
And that's another reason
why I like this character.
As much as this
character, like I said,
says a lot of
inappropriate stuff,
they give me some
funny lines to say.
So end of the day, if people
are watching it and going
like, oh, that dude made me
laugh, and he's got an accent
and he seems like he's
from an Arab country.
Well, you know, that'd be great.
If people like that
character, then that's
one little [INTERPOSING VOICES].
JERMAINE FOWLER: You also
come from a conservative,
you have a
conservative viewpoint.
MAZ JOBRANI: Yeah, he's got
a conservative viewpoint,
this character.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yeah,
the Iraqi guy on our show
has a conservative viewpoint.
And it's so funny,
because he basically
thinks the way most
Americans might think.
They might see some
similarities in this guy,
it's just so cool that it comes
from a Middle Eastern fellow.
DAVID KOECHNER:
And a real place.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
DAVID KOECHNER: With Maz.
MAZ JOBRANI: I'm definitely
very conservative now.
That's actually fun for me, too.
I get to play a character that's
very different than who I am.
So I get to lampoon
it on a weekly basis.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Koechner,
yours is very close to you.
DAVID KOECHNER: Yes.
Disenfranchised
middle-aged white guy.
SPEAKER 2: Let's talk
about the set, right?
So here at Google, we're always
talking about being authentic,
being yourself.
You guys clearly
are very authentic.
You started very
authentic, you are.
But I'd love to know how
that parlays into how
you interact on the set.
And I'm actually going to
direct this question to Rell
because you're right next to me.
I know that you wrote a
show for Comedy Central
and you've had that
experience, and obviously
several stand-up
comedy experiences.
For yourself, when you go
into work, and it's like, OK,
it's showtime, how do you
bring your authentic uniqueness
to your role?
RELL BATTLE: Well, my
character's name is Sweatpants.
I got a cousin named Lil Pookie.
Well, what it is
is I get to be--
I don't have to--
I probably have the
easiest job of everybody.
Because I know a
thousand cool dudes who
just smoke a lot of
pot and living off
of their best friend, you know?
I was that guy.
I went to the
University of Maryland.
Any Terps?
Just me?
Cool.
You a Terp?
Hell, yeah.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Are you serious?
Yo, what up, man?
RELL BATTLE: Jermaine
didn't go to college.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I worked around
there at the dry cleaners.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MAZ JOBRANI: In real life, he's
Sweatpants and you're Franco.
He was sleeping in your--
RELL BATTLE: But you
know, I got the cool job.
Just coming in and
saying something funny,
and getting out.
I get to be free and loose
and as goofy as I want to be.
And just be a slacker.
So it's not hard for any kid
that was smoking a lot of weed
back in college.
So I have the
easiest of the jobs.
But that person is represented
in every city, any good friend,
you know what I mean?
My job is to be loyal
to Franco's character
and I think I'm a
pretty loyal friend.
So, I got the easiest--
I think I got the easiest job.
JERMAINE FOWLER: You do.
SPEAKER 2: Cool.
David, what about you?
DAVID KOECHNER: Oh, yes.
SPEAKER 2: Same questions.
DAVID KOECHNER:
What was the exact--
SPEAKER 2: The question
was, how can you break--
DAVID KOECHNER: Can you
restate the question please?
SPEAKER 2: How do you bring
your uniqueness to your role?
DAVID KOECHNER: I
guess because I've
been doing this for
30 years, there's
only one way I
know how to do it.
No, I was fortunate
enough to just get hired.
And so they allowed me to find
certain quirks and mannerisms
in the character that
reflected my personality.
And I think I'm a
good enough actor
to understand what they needed
from me, script-wise, too.
So I would say that's it.
Just experience.
SPEAKER 2: What
about you, Jermaine?
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's funny, I
got a cousin named Pookie, too.
SPEAKER 2: Everybody's
got a cousin named Pookie.
Everybody's got a
cousin named Pookie.
RELL BATTLE: This ain't for
everybody, just for us three.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MAZ JOBRANI: I don't have
a cousin named Pookie.
I do not.
Poo-yah.
SPEAKER 2: Most
African-Americans
have a Pookie
somewhere in the line.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Why Pookie?
SPEAKER 2: I don't know.
RELL BATTLE: It's like
Dave for everybody else.
DAVID KOECHNER: Oh,
so he's a cool guy.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Kevin Hart's business
manager's name is Pookie.
RELL BATTLE: You got the
same business manager.
His name's Pookie.
It sounds bad, but
he's really good.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Pookie's smart.
You know what's funny is
when I first got the job,
I was extremely nervous.
It was my first
multi-cam sitcom role.
And I was like, all right,
just copy Katey and Judd.
Just copy Katey and Judd.
SPEAKER 2: Maybe tell us
what multi-cam sitcom means.
JERMAINE FOWLER: A bunch
of cameras in a live studio
audience setting.
MAZ JOBRANI: Four cameras and
it's in front of a live studio.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Excuse
me if I wasn't clear.
RELL BATTLE: "The
Office" is single cam,
if y'all used to
watch "The Office."
JERMAINE FOWLER: "Master
of None," "Cheers."
Single cam, "Master
of None," and you
got "Cheers," multi-cam.
There we go.
I was nervous.
And I realized that,
all right, cool.
What similarities do I have
with the character and myself?
I used to be broke, looking
for a job around Maryland.
I used that desperation
for the pilot.
And as the season went on, we
used different subject matter
and different storylines.
I always tried to
find similarities
within the plots and the
scenes that I could relate to.
And I always brought
that to the scenes.
But Judd and Katey, man.
I really just watched
the hell out of them.
Shit, when they talk,
I shut the hell up.
SPEAKER 2: Awesome.
And Maz, what about yourself?
I think you've kind
of answered it,
but I didn't want
to neglect you.
MAZ JOBRANI: No, no,
ask your next question
because I thought I
did answer it, right?
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: All right, cool.
MAZ JOBRANI: No,
I'm being efficient.
SPEAKER 2: The next
season is coming out.
What do you want
us, as Googlers--
and Googlers is the term we
use for ourselves internally.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Ooh.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, you guys
are on the inside now.
Googlers.
What messaging do you want
us, as Googlers, to know?
And what would you
encourage us to--
I mean, obviously,
look at the show--
but what should we know about
this next season coming out?
DAVID KOECHNER: We just
want you to live tweet it
during the show.
RELL BATTLE: That'd be great.
That'd be really cool.
MAZ JOBRANI: I'm a big fan of
all the serialized shows that
are out there.
The "Game of Thrones"
and the "House of Cards"
and all those shows.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
"Rick and Morty."
MAZ JOBRANI: But this is a
show that's not serialized.
It's a show that you can tune
in, watch a few episodes,
and then skip to
the next, whatever.
JERMAINE FOWLER: You can watch
it while you're washing dishes.
MAZ JOBRANI: Jump around.
I honestly feel the writers have
done a great job this season
of doing some
really funny stuff.
There was scripts that I read
before we did the table read,
and I was laughing out loud.
So there was some good,
funny stuff in there.
So it's a good way to get
some light entertainment
while we touch on some serious
subjects, but in a light way.
And hey, everybody
needs to laugh.
I mean, the world is
crazier than ever.
So once you've been bombarded
with your daily news
about Trump and
Russia and Korea,
and wherever else
we're going to--
tune in to us and
laugh a little bit.
DAVID KOECHNER: Is it too
much to say we're here
to unburden you of your pain?
MAZ JOBRANI: Social barometer.
What was it?
What was your word?
DAVID KOECHNER:
Cultural barometer.
MAZ JOBRANI: Cultural barometer.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Katey Sagal
plays a cop, and she's awesome.
Judd Hirsch is cooking donuts.
Watch the damn show.
It's going to be really good.
SPEAKER 2: Very cool.
We're super excited
that you took some time.
We know this has been a
super long day for you,
so thank you for coming
here to talk to us.
And it's not just,
obviously, this audience,
but a lot of people are
going to be seeing this
throughout Google, so we
just really appreciate--
you guys are hilarious.
And it's awesome to hear
that you guys are going
to be at Zanies tonight
because it sounds like that's
going to be a really good time.
JERMAINE FOWLER: The show
is sold out, so that sucks.
Y'all can, I guess,
come afterwards and--
MAZ JOBRANI: Just Google us--
JERMAINE FOWLER: --say hi.
MAZ JOBRANI: --the
next time you want
to see us live, just Google
us and you'll see us.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Or Bing.
Bing is pretty hot, you know?
SPEAKER 2: What?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Remember Bing?
SPEAKER 2: Who?
DAVID KOECHNER: That's
a curse word here.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
I'm fucking around.
What happened to Bing?
Did y'all kill Bing?
RELL BATTLE: Of course they
killed Bing, they're Google.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
I was auditioning
for a Bing commercial back in
like [? 2013 ?] or something
like that.
MAZ JOBRANI: Bing bombed,
that's what happened.
Bing bomb.
I heard it.
They're done.
SPEAKER 2: So we
are going to give
the audience an opportunity
to ask a few questions.
I know I've been
dominating here,
but that's what I
was supposed to do.
So if anybody has
questions, just because this
is being recorded,
we would like for you
to go to the microphone
in the middle.
RELL BATTLE: Don't all jump
at the same time, guys.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
He already did it.
AUDIENCE: My question is
actually for [? Lila. ?]
Where did you get those
googly sneakers from?
RELL BATTLE: I was
thinking the same thing.
Are those Pumas?
My sisters would love those.
SPEAKER 2: Nordstrom.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Are those Sauconys?
SPEAKER 2: I don't know
if I can say the brand.
JERMAINE FOWLER: They're Bings.
SPEAKER 2: You're so awesome.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
What's up, buddy?
AUDIENCE: Hey, quick question.
So being comedians
on a comedy show,
and having written your
own stuff in the past,
do you ever find yourself
funnier than the writers?
And then do you guys get input
into really re-crafting some?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yes.
As a stand-up comic, I hate--
RELL BATTLE: I plead the Fifth.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Come on, Rell.
I honestly do, sometimes.
Because you're a comic.
You've been writing
your stuff for years.
Then-- I'm very
selfish sometimes,
when it comes to my comedy.
I just want to make
sure whatever I'm
saying is going to be funny.
But you just want to
have some sort of control
over what you're saying.
They do a good job, honestly.
They're really, really funny.
RELL BATTLE: We all want to lift
the material any way we can,
if we can.
We always want to do
the best job possible,
have the best show on TV.
JERMAINE FOWLER: That's
because we're stand-ups.
RELL BATTLE: And it's like
having four extra writers,
really.
If you really think about it.
Now, if we get to
keep our stuff,
that's a different story.
MAZ JOBRANI: They allow
us, on show night,
to maybe do a take with
some of the ideas we have.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Crazy take, fun take.
MAZ JOBRANI: But there's
a lot of good writers,
so even show night, they come
up with alternative lines.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
There's 14 writers
and it all gets filtered, and
it's a very collaborative show.
Everybody wants the
show to be good,
and as long as it gets that
way, then we're just fine.
AUDIENCE: Dynamic.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Uh-huh.
As hell.
DAVID KOECHNER: The
format lends itself
to a certain style of comedy
that we all know we're in for.
So--
RELL BATTLE: Are they
going to watch this?
Never mind, nope.
DAVID KOECHNER:
They might still,
but we didn't say anything bad.
RELL BATTLE: Neh-mind.
Nope.
SPEAKER 2: Did you
just say "neh-mind"?
RELL BATTLE: Never mind.
SPEAKER 2: Did you
just pull off the E-R--
RELL BATTLE: It's after 1:00.
After 1:00.
AUDIENCE: I know you guys have
been in the stand-up comedy
game for a long time
and it's a long road
to get where you
guys are now today,
so I was wondering
if one of you could
share a story of the early days
of when you were starting off.
Any bad gigs you had
or memorable, bizarre
experiences starting
out on the road?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Oh, man.
MAZ JOBRANI: There's
all kinds of them, man.
Because the thing is,
when you first start out,
you gig everywhere you can.
Coffee shops, bars,
church basements.
I did a church basement
where there was
eight people in the audience.
And then I realized they
were all there to perform,
so we would just rotate.
[LAUGHTER]
We would rotate.
You'd finish, you'd sit,
the next guy would come up.
You felt bad leaving,
because you're like,
oh, he watched mine,
I'll watch his.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I did
a country club and just
a bunch of old white dudes, man.
And my comedy ain't for them.
So I did it and I bombed
so bad, I told the booker,
keep the money.
I needed the money for rent.
And he was like, OK.
MAZ JOBRANI: So he
agreed with you.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
He agreed with me.
He kept the money, man.
DAVID KOECHNER: I started
in sketch and improv,
so there's plenty
of nights where
you have a small audience
or some people who
just aren't down with it.
The worst one being Mayfield
Park, the racetrack.
We did a show there.
The stage was bad, the lights
were bad, the crowd was worse.
But you don't
blame the audience.
You've got to find out
where there funny bone is
and tickle it.
So not their fault. But
those are always a tough one.
But at least I had
other people with me.
RELL BATTLE: I did a Gong Show
at The Comedy Store one time.
I don't know why I did that.
And this is like--
remember Facebook was
just like a college thing?
And it wasn't like-- the
general public didn't have it.
Well, nobody told me, right?
So I'm on this Gong
Show, I do this joke.
You know, ladies-- it was real
hacky-- ladies, if I send you
a friends request on Facebook,
and you accept, we together.
That was the punch--
that was the hit, right?
And this was killing
in college, right?
And I do this show and Facebook
hadn't came out at that time.
And everybody was just
like, what's Facebook?
And then I heard from the back,
somebody says, next comedian.
And it was the bouncer of
the comedy club saying that.
So I stopped doing
comedy for six months.
JERMAINE FOWLER: That's why
you took the six-month break.
SPEAKER 2: That leads me
to probably a very obvious
question around failure, right?
So many people-- oh,
I'm sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Kind of related.
My friend who is
sitting next to me
is an up-and-coming stand-up
comedian here in Chicago.
She had to leave for a meeting.
She wanted to know--
RELL BATTLE: Why isn't
she up there telling the--
AUDIENCE: She had to leave
for a very important meeting.
Do you have any advice
for, specifically women,
coming up in comedy right now?
MAZ JOBRANI: Just
get up on stage
as much as you can and
write as much as you can.
For a man, woman, child.
Child, you probably should
be home doing your homework.
Just get up and write
as much as you can.
That's it.
Go, go, go, go,
you figure it out.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Mulaney
gave me some advice
when I first started.
MySpace was big.
I MySpace'd Mulaney.
Hey man, you're from Georgetown.
I live in DC.
How do I get big or whatever.
And he's like, well, you
know, if you're not writing,
get on stage.
If you're not on stage,
make sure you write.
And it was the most
simple concept.
I was like, oh.
And it's one thing
people forget.
Just write and get on stage.
Fail.
You've got to fail.
The more you experience
success early on,
when failure hits you, you're
not going to be ready for it.
It's just going to
hit you really hard.
So bomb as much as you can.
Find yourself early, so
when those opportunities
come your way you'll
know how to deal with it.
Bless you.
MAZ JOBRANI: Excuse me.
JERMAINE FOWLER: And
that's my advice.
AUDIENCE: Between networks
and Netflix and Hulu,
do you guys think that
there's too much TV and video
content right now?
RELL BATTLE: I actually
think there is.
I think stand-up is really
over-saturated, personally.
I think it's too much.
At the same time, we
can all work way more.
I just think, as a fan, I'm
like, oh, this is watered down
and it's very hard to find,
I think, quality stuff.
As an actor, as a
comedian, great.
Keep giving us money.
So if I wasn't a comedian,
I would be like--
I don't know what
you guys think,
I can't tell from
that perspective.
But to me, I think it is a lot.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's weird
because every big movie comes
out--
a good one comes out
like twice a month.
And Netflix puts out a special
once every Tuesday or so.
RELL BATTLE: A Netflix
movie every freaking--
JERMAINE FOWLER: And special.
It gets a little too much
because you can't really
keep up.
And that just
over-saturates the market.
You can't really enjoy one
or find your guy or the one
you want to watch,
when one in your queue
gets flushed over because
another one's popped up.
And it's a lot.
It's a lot of stand-up comedy.
RELL BATTLE: I just
start watching "Curb."
I'm never going to get
to "Stranger Things."
You know what I'm saying?
I'm stuck.
What am I supposed to do?
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's a lot.
But it's also a blessing
because, you know,
a lot of opportunities
for comics are happening
and people can finally--
there isn't just Comedy--
when I was just starting,
it was just Comedy Central.
RELL BATTLE: I don't
think Netflix was out.
HBO was--
JERMAINE FOWLER: No, it
was just Comedy Central,
and they were like
the gatekeepers.
And now a lot of people
working at Comedy Central
work at Netflix.
So it's pretty cool
to watch that happen.
RELL BATTLE: It does take the
power away from certain people.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It does, and
I'm very happy about that.
SPEAKER 2: So it
democratizes it.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It really does.
RELL BATTLE: You
guys don't know what
it's like not to have power.
But for everybody--
other networks,
it takes the power away
from a Comedy Central.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Yeah.
Like Hulu, Seeso are
getting in on it,
and it's pretty remarkable
to see all that.
But the problem is now
there's a lot of specials,
so it's your job to
find the ones you like.
But all that takes is
going to live comedy shows
and supporting.
Seeing the person you like
and really just following
their career.
AUDIENCE: I used to work
with John Montgomery
at Leo Burnett, when
he would carry around
a suitcase full of
ideas for TV shows.
And he was one of my
favorite people to work with.
I'm just curious how you
guys like working with John.
JERMAINE FOWLER: John's dope.
MAZ JOBRANI: For the rest
of them that don't know,
John Montgomery is one of our
exec producers as well as a--
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Native Chicago guy.
MAZ JOBRANI: Mark
Teitelbaum, these two guys.
And, yeah, your
question, we love him.
He's such a sweetheart.
And these two were
the ones who found
the project in the first
place from Tracy Letts, right?
DAVID KOECHNER: John is a
friend of Tracy's, yeah.
RELL BATTLE: John and Mark
Teitelbaum over there.
John's the guy who looks like
Harold Ramis in the back.
Right there.
Mark's right there, sitting
alone with the black jacket.
DAVID KOECHNER: So
we're grateful for John,
because if not for him,
this show wouldn't exist.
RELL BATTLE: And I'll
tell you how great
it is working with John.
I was dating a girl at the time,
and I bought her to the set,
and she was so bored
during the taping.
And John was like, you
know what you need?
Some magic tricks.
Breaks out the cards,
give it to her,
she was happy for
the rest of the day.
How could I not want
that as a producer?
JERMAINE FOWLER: One of
the writers on the show
is afraid of magic, and she's
afraid to tell John that.
John, every time you
pull out your cards,
she walks away because she
can't handle the magic.
She goes, oh I can't
do it, I can't do it.
RELL BATTLE: When you
bring a girl to set,
take her over to John.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
That was awesome.
John's a good dude.
He's a great tour
guide too, in Chicago.
SPEAKER 2: So one
of the question's
I was going to ask
earlier, you've mentioned,
hey, get up there, fail
as much as you can.
Oftentimes people talk about,
hey failure, have as many
at bats, or swing it out
as many times as you can.
But even though that's
true, most people
avoid it like the plague.
And so, the question is,
clearly with what all of you do,
you're dealing with failure
right on all the time, right?
People either like
you, or they don't.
The question is, how
do you rebound, right?
There has to have been times
when you didn't deal with it so
easily or maybe you
deal with failure really
well as a stand up
comedian, or as an actor,
but you don't deal
with it so well
in other areas of your life.
So what have you done to be
successful to manage that?
MAZ JOBRANI: That's why you've
got to find what you love,
and that's why, again, I
think you guys are probably
in the field--
I hope you're in the
field-- that you love.
All the stories you
hear about Bill Gates
being in that garage for so
long, or any of these guys
who founded these companies,
just going, and going,
and going.
I studied poli sci undergrad.
I started a PhD
program in poli sci.
I dropped out.
Throughout my early 20s, I
tried my hand at different jobs.
And I wasn't
passionate about them.
So when I wouldn't do
well at them, I'd be like,
you know what?
I quit.
But finally, when I found this,
even though it was a bad night,
it wasn't a failure.
It was like, OK, I'll
come back again tomorrow.
Because I really was passionate.
I really loved it.
I had to do it the next day.
As a matter of fact,
when I had a bad night,
I couldn't wait to get
back up to almost get--
it's like a baseball
player probably
wants to get that hit again.
I wanted to just get up, get
a hit, get a pretty good set,
and be like, OK, I'm going
to put that behind me.
So in the same way,
I think if you really
can find your passion,
then your failures
are just part of the road.
Because you can't
succeed 100% of the time.
And if you are,
you're delusional.
RELL BATTLE: I think it's
also great to have friends who
do the same thing that you do.
Because I know, as
comedians, we fail together.
I will come back
like, oh, man, I just
bombed the Laugh Factory.
And my boy will be like, I
bombed at the Comedy Store
and I got in a fight with
one of the audience members.
Like oof, your night was
way worse than my shit.
It's like, all right.
This is one thing
about the comedy clubs,
you can always hear a
worse story that night.
Somebody always had it worse.
And I hate to say it, it
makes you feel better.
One day, you're going to
have that worse story.
But every night I went and
I was upset and bothered
and frustrated, somebody
always was like,
man, my money only
came-- half of the money.
Well, I'm getting
evicted tomorrow, bro.
So it's like, OK,
well you know what?
I'm going to try tomorrow.
We're going to be good.
And you know, people's
pain makes me feel better.
Is that the point?
I don't know.
DAVID KOECHNER: Plus, you
have success somewhere.
People like to hear
failure stories,
but there's a lot of success.
And so you just build on that.
I think a lot of it, too,
is you make your decision
and that's it.
That will go your way and you
just keep that in your heart,
like I'm going to succeed.
And then, hopefully, you're able
to see enough success that that
helps you build to your dream.
Because I've known people, too,
that hang in there for years,
and you're just like, no
one has encouraged you once,
and that's almost
more admirable.
People that have no
success, yet stay in it.
But ultimately, they'll
usually opt out.
Yeah, I think you just,
you've got to believe.
You make that decision
and you just go full head.
RELL BATTLE: And once you
get there, it's so sweet.
You guys, this is Google.
Like, it doesn't get better
than this, I'm assuming, right?
In the tech world.
OK, maybe it does.
Never mind.
You guys are looking at me--
DAVID KOECHNER: There's a lot
of free water, and free food.
It's pretty good.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I liked
that when I was broke
living in Washington
Heights in New York,
I was sleeping on his air
mattress and I was sad.
But I read Steve Martin's bio.
And that really
just opened my eyes
a little bit about, oh,
the struggle is real.
And Hannibal's "What the Fuck"
episode, Mark Maron's podcast.
RELL BATTLE: Yeah,
that was pretty good.
JERMAINE FOWLER: When
he slept on the train,
I was like, me too.
When you hear similar stories,
like Rell was talking about,
it really does help you
realize, oh, hey, I'm
not the only one
going through this.
I think Amy Poehler has a
dope book about her first
moving to New York.
Part of success is failure.
Probably you get most of failure
before you get to the success,
you know?
But once you get there, like
Rell said, it's really sweet.
It's a beautiful thing.
And for the most part,
now that I'm here,
I appreciate me failing so much
because those were the best
stories.
I go back home to Brooklyn and
I talk to my old comedy buddies,
and I talk to them
about times that we
used to get wasted and
annoy people so much
they would fight each other.
We didn't know how we
did it, but we were just
mean comics, man.
We were just going
through a lot at the time.
And it was just great.
But having similar
stories is very helpful
when you're going through
that type of stuff.
SPEAKER 2: That's awesome.
By the way, a late
congratulations
to having a beautiful baby girl.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Thank you, Lila.
I appreciate that.
[APPLAUSE]
RELL BATTLE: She's gorgeous.
She looks just like him.
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's weird.
My little daughter
looks like me,
so that's unfortunate for her.
But she's so cool.
She's getting taller.
I think she might be
taller than me when she
gets older, which is awesome.
People always ask me,
what's it like to be a dad?
I don't have a word for it.
It's awesome.
It's beautiful and
she's like, I can't
wait to go back home to
see her tomorrow, man.
It's going to be great.
We're going to dress her up
as Chuckie for Halloween.
She's the right size
for the costume.
SPEAKER 2: Are there any other--
yeah, we got another question.
AUDIENCE: So Chicago plays a big
role in your show, obviously.
And some of you have spent
a lot of time in Chicago.
Is there anything
that you're super
excited to do while you're
here or see, or just--
RELL BATTLE: We want to
go to Millennial Park
and do social media pictures.
Isn't that right, Shauna?
DAVID KOECHNER: Hopefully
it's going to be dark
when we get out of here.
JERMAINE FOWLER: Might be
a little too dark to do it.
RELL BATTLE: But it'll be so
exciting to take social media
pictures at Millennial Park.
DAVID KOECHNER: We
haven't had much time.
We got it last night
and we're all pretty
exhausted because we've
been traveling every day.
And today, we had
to get up at 4:45
to leave the hotel at 5:15.
We did get some
Giordano's pizza today.
JERMAINE FOWLER: We got
Gio's and we feel like shit.
DAVID KOECHNER: We got that in.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
It was a mistake.
I want to actually
go to Wiener's Circle
with Dave Koechner.
DAVID KOECHNER:
I'm not a big fan.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MAZ JOBRANI: Oh yeah,
I've been there.
It's pretty funny.
RELL BATTLE: I have
never been there.
DAVID KOECHNER: If
we had another day,
we would be able to--
JERMAINE FOWLER: It's all good.
It's all good.
But I don't know.
I actually wanted to do
a "Dark Knight" tour.
Because I'm a big ass nerd.
So I want to try and
do that actually.
We went to the underpass
where the Joker drives.
MAZ JOBRANI: Jermaine is
actually looking for Batman.
He won't believe us.
We're like, he's not real.
[LAUGHTER]
JERMAINE FOWLER:
I'm like, he is.
I'm a huge nerd.
I want to try and
do that, actually,
so I'm going to go on Google
and find the landmarks.
DAVID KOECHNER: We did a
segment at Second City today,
so that was fun.
Some of these guys
hadn't been there before.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I did the
Rock Tour in San Francisco.
You ever do that?
DAVID KOECHNER: You mean--
JERMAINE FOWLER: Sean
Connery and Nicholas Cage.
DAVID KOECHNER: Oh, no.
I didn't know there was one.
JERMAINE FOWLER: There wasn't.
I just Googled the places.
DAVID KOECHNER: I'm
going to Alcatraz.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I've never
been to Alcatraz, man.
DAVID KOECHNER: Should have
been first on the Rock Tour.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
Well, it wasn't.
[LAUGHTER]
It was a huge line to do it.
I didn't have time.
SPEAKER 2: We have
another question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, just one more.
What were your favorite sitcoms
either growing up, or just
of all time?
MAZ JOBRANI: Mine was
"Cheers" and "Taxi".
DAVID KOECHNER: Yeah, "Taxi."
I liked Abbot and Costello's
movies and Monty Python.
SNL was big.
Marx brothers.
I'm done.
RELL BATTLE: As far
as sitcoms, I mean,
I'm from DC, as
well as Jermaine.
So "Martin" was the world.
"Martin" was everything.
I didn't care about
nothing else, but "Martin."
JERMAINE FOWLER: "Martin."
RELL BATTLE: My early moments--
I never told Katey this, but
I had the biggest crush on her
because "Married With
Children" was the show.
JERMAINE FOWLER: I think
we still do, actually.
RELL BATTLE: "Married
with Children,"
my dad and I used to watch that.
"All In The Family"
was really great.
I think it's similar.
A lot of issues that
we talk about now.
I've never seen
"Seinfeld" because it
was on at the same
time as "Martin."
And as a comedian,
that's like a sin.
I'm like, I don't
know what happened.
Who's Kramer?
But I know who Sheneneh was.
SPEAKER 2: Sheneneh.
Was Sheneneh "Martin"?
JERMAINE FOWLER: Does
"Ren and Stimpy" count?
I used to watch
that all the time.
RELL BATTLE: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: I thought that was--
RELL BATTLE: Martin
played Sheneneh.
You didn't know that?
This interview's over.
JERMAINE FOWLER: You didn't
know Martin played that hideous
woman?
SPEAKER 2: No.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
That was Martin.
RELL BATTLE: Wow, we got to do
a lot of work after this show.
We got to talk.
DAVID KOECHNER: I'd say "Mash,"
too, was big for me as a kid.
JERMAINE FOWLER: "Mash" came
on at 4:00 in the morning
when I was a kid, so
I couldn't watch it.
It always came on really,
really early for some reason.
The reruns for some reason.
RELL BATTLE: He played
Sheneneh, Otus, Dragonfly Jones.
SPEAKER 2: I did not know that.
RELL BATTLE: I'm giving
you a class on "Martin."
SPEAKER 2: Must have
been before my time.
Anyway, any other-- or not.
And other questions
from the audience?
RELL BATTLE: They're ready to go
back and make flying cars now.
SPEAKER 2: Well,
I will say this,
considering the fact that
you all were up at 4:45
or whatever, we are extremely
grateful that you even passed
by and stopped by to say
hello to us and chat.
You guys are clearly very funny.
I haven't laughed this
much this whole week.
Of course, it just started.
So thanks again.
And good luck with the show.
I know I'm going to tune in.
MAZ JOBRANI: Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
JERMAINE FOWLER:
[APPLAUSE]
Are they engineers or marketers?
Who are we talking to?